The David Pakman Show at David Pakman Dotcom.
So there's a new propaganda war being waged
right now that was triggered by Donald Trump's
suspension from Twitter and is growing because
of the distancing that many for profit businesses
have decided they want to make from the right
wing social media app Parler.
And I have news for everybody who's furious
about what's happening to parler.
WOAK mobs are not destroying parler.
Regulation is not destroying parler.
The government is not destroying parler.
Hackers are not destroying parler.
Capitalism is solely to blame for what is
happening to parler.
Capitalism is responsible for Parlor's demise.
Apple and Amazon have removed parler from
their services because as for profit companies,
they can do whatever the hell they want, partially
because Republicans have refused to regulate
them.
They are making business decisions that they
determined are best for them, and they are
making these decisions within a free market
in which you and I as consumers can also decide,
wow, I don't like what Apple did to parler.
So now I'm going to boycott Apple or I can
decide, you know what I like what Apple did
to parler.
I'm going to go and buy 10 iPhones if I want
to do that.
Google decided to remove Parler from their
app store because they say parler isn't sufficiently
policing user posts.
And so a whole bunch of posts that encourage
and incite violence and crime are remaining
on the platform.
And there are people who are furious and saying,
well, hold on a second, Google is kind of
a monopoly.
So how can you say, well, if they're not on
Google, on the Google Play App Store, then
you can get parler because Google has a lot
of market power.
Well, where were these exact same Republicans
when Elizabeth Warren was saying we've got
to deal with the monopoly power of these companies?
They were against it, these same Republicans
who now are saying.
But but but they have monopoly power.
They were against dealing with monopoly power.
When we on the left were sounding the alarm
about the lack of antitrust enforcement, which
was allowing monopoly power to grow unchecked
in the United States.
So there's a real irony in that unregulated
capitalism and the legalization of pseudo
monopolies are responsible for the downfall
of this far right social media platform because
the party that has been asking for more capitalism
and more corporate freedom got it.
And now they're furious that they have that
freedom.
And it has led to a free market of ideas and
decisions in which many companies decided
we don't want anything to do with parler.
Nobody's preventing the people at Parler from
hosting their own servers and paying for them.
That's how capitalism works.
And much like Fox News is now being destroyed
by the monster they created, now that Fox
News is not quite radical enough for some
people, Fox News is losing some of their own
radical audience to Newsmax and on.
That's the same mechanism that's at play here.
The only question I have is whether the right
is pretending not to understand this or if
they genuinely don't understand that this
is a circumstance of their own making.
No one's First Amendment rights have been
silenced here.
Everyone can say whatever the hell they want,
but there are for profit companies saying
we don't want anything to do with what Parla
is offering.
Amazon isn't required to provide hosting services
to parler when Parlo allows members to violate
the terms and conditions for Amazon, hosting
Amazon will lose money because they lose parler
as a client.
But that's Amazon's call to make.
And by the way, let's go even further.
And massacre's, by the way, being removed
from places of business by business owners.
That's not government regulation.
That's a company deciding what's best for
us is not to have anti maskers here.
That's something they're allowed to do.
DC rioters being put on no fly lists because
airlines have decided they don't want their
business or corporations saying you were at
the DC riots, you're fired.
We don't want you working for us.
That's the free market.
And lots of the people crying about free speech,
first of all, don't understand what it means.
And secondly, think that free speech means
freedom from consequences to your speech.
The consequences to your speech in the free
market are part of free speech.
The speech and the consequences are all part
of speech.
And remember that when we want to talk about
the First Amendment, we have to be talking
about the government, which is yet another
detail that seems to be missed here.
Now you are going to hear and in fact, we're
going to talk about it in the next segment.
You are going to hear that all of these.
Companies are limiting the First Amendment
rights of individuals that these companies
are engaged in censorship or whatever the
case may be, go back and check out the interview
I did with a First Amendment legal scholar
about the misunderstandings that people have
about what that even means.
I know many of you know it, but in case many
of you don't check that out and let's now
discuss a continued misunderstanding, deliberate
or not, on the Tucker Carlson program